my problem was kind of hilarious I went
with a very good guy friend of mine and
another couple on a double date and I
actually made out with the other guy's
prom date so technically my problem is
pretty great
[Music]
I never got to have a problem this is my
first prom I went with a good friend of
mine who was in school with and she and
I used to like laugh constantly so we
had a good time and we matched we were
both in like black featuring red I
definitely stood out I went to an all
boy Jesuit school in Miami where I was
closeted because in the 90s that's what
you did in high school my problem was a
lot of fun I just remember me and my
friends renting a limo and we just party
from the time we got in the limo to the
time we got back dropped off at home I
had a good time it was definitely
traditional we got like the corsages
what are they called corsage corsage oh
I was prom King I was very popular I was
Captain of my cheerleading squad too I
actually did not attend prom I didn't go
because I didn't really feel comfortable
enough in my sexuality or my gender
expression to really go to prom with
someone who I'd like to go with and what
I wanted to wear I went to prom with a
close friend of mine who ended up
dancing all night with a guy that she
liked and you know I had a good time but
I ended up alone it's a prom I went with
the girl because it wasn't okay to be
out it was a great night but it wasn't a
night where I was who I was fully
prom oh I didn't go to prom because I
knew I was a gay boy living in a very
southern city so when I heard that
BuzzFeed was doing a queer prom I
thought that was the most amazing
special thing on earth
[Music]
depending on where these kids are are
located their schools might not be open
to this kind of a thing and even if
their schools do have an open door
policy they might not feel comfortable
so this is a safe space tonight I think
that it's so important for queer kids to
see other queer kids living
authentically to see all these young
lgbtq plus people together it really
builds community and I think that's
something that lgbtq young people don't
really get a lot of I'm so so happy to
be like you know in in this lifetime
where we have queer prompts and we have
pride in high school it's just an
amazing thing so I love it I just think
it's important in general to get
together and just celebrate who you are
it's so important to express
individuality absolutely and
togetherness at the same time especially
in this political climate and it's so
unbelievable that one of the biggest
websites in the world BuzzFeed is
putting on an event that's just like
completely inclusive of queer kids and
so all these people around America and
around the world are seeing these videos
and they're thinking wow I'm not alone
alone things like this are happening
when I grew up I didn't have anything
like this I didn't have this kind of
visibility to see and to feel the
support there's like a box of like
typical problems like to see something
like this would have been like really
really cool like you would have had
ideas and like just felt empowered to
like show up to your mom wearing
whatever you want problem is usually
like a cisgender heteronormative like
tradition yeah times have changed so
much and it's beautiful to see kids be
able to celebrate who they are in the
fullness of who they are that's the last
thing you want to be thinking about is
are you allowed to go there because you
choose to go with who you like you love
you know so I think it's important to
have events like this to raise awareness
that this is something that we're not
going to tolerate in the society that
America is better than this that people
are the same and equal
my queer is story also mini girl
okay that's that's maybe a little too
dirty two years ago at the Grammys you
wore like a full dress moment I did wear
a dress to the Grammys and it was bold
and it was beautiful and he got all
raving reviews I was once in a hug with
Ellen Degeneres and Ellen Page I don't
know if it gets any clearer than that
we're awesome I got to open Britney
Spears circus tour that's pretty major
it's an opening for Kesha at my first
prize felt pretty queer and pretty
amazing I was partially raised by a
member of the LGBT community I'm
straight but I've always kind of been
put in that box I feel like I definitely
connect and understand what the
experience is honestly when I started to
get into glitter on my face like it's
probably in the last like year or
actually a few months actually oh I'm
just all Queer all the time I mean I
don't know if you could classify one as
being more queer than the other I'm like
a unicorn I mean you can't see the horn
it's invisible
you are not wrong
period you're not wrong and don't ever
let anybody make you feel wrong for just
being you keep resisting and keep uh
being yourself regardless of what people
tell you to do because Society is really
good at saying Oh Be Yourself oh wait
but not like that but enough of that
[ __ ] be yourself and shove it in
people's faces if you're at home as a
teenager dealing with bullying for
difficult people I would say that it's
important to stay true to yourself the
community is much larger than we think
it is at times and I remember growing up
feeling like it's this big and once you
kind of make these connections
kind of opens that up the people who
matter don't care and the people who
care don't matter I think if anybody's
out there and they feel like they don't
belong at prom
all those kids wrong find a crew to go
with grow with your friends go with it
with a date I know it's hard and I know
High School makes it very difficult but
if you're at a dance
it's your memory it's not their memory
so do it for you you belong everywhere
and sometimes the prom in some places
isn't just the best place for you but
you can make that experience somewhere
else and it doesn't have to be at the
school or in the gym you have something
to give you have something to offer this
world it definitely gets better and just
try to enjoy it and I would say just be
yourself like no Shameless be yourself
absolutely have fun and live your life
you only get one chance at this and you
have to do it your way
foreign
[Music]